Avec le temps, j'ai réalisé médicalement que
les dommages causés à ma famille
pas mes enfants
a ma mère
parce qu'en eux-mêmes, c'étaient eux qui
ils se sentaient pire que moi et ça me fait mal
non pourquoi
ce sont eux qui ont été touchés, ils étaient petits
et
[Musique]
convient aux personnes qui ont le
une situation économique précaire arrive
des gens qui vivent des choses comme ça
non, alors les besoins économiques
alors ils cherchent, ils voient qui
dans ce cas, c'était moi alors
ce
Eh bien, ils ne se soucient pas de ce qu'ils font
ils veulent, c'est gagner
[Musique]
et
Oh
Yo
ils ont besoin d'un évent
et puis ils me racontent leur vie
histoires leur tristesse aussi leur
réjouis tes espoirs
cette année
dedans ou ton nom est une tentation
[Musique]
il
homme
et
s'ils se comportent